everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve maximum depth of a binary tree
and the main reason i'm solving this
today is just for the sake of completion
we have solved harder tree problems
before
but this one is on the blind 75 list so
i do want to solve this problem
today and this problem actually has
multiple ways to solve it so i do think
it's a good problem to understand of
like the fundamentals on uh tree
traversals we can do it three different
ways and i'm actually going to show
the three different ways there might
even be more than three but i'm going to
show you the three main ways
basically recursive depth first search
iterative depth
first search basically depth first
search without using recursion
and of course another way is going to be
breadth first search
so i'm going to be showing all three
today so the problem is pretty simple
we're given a root binary tree and we
want to return its maximum depth and the
maximum depth is defined as being
the longest path from the root
to one of the no to one of the leaf
nodes and basically along that path
we're counting the number of nodes so in
this case you can see we have two paths
that are of the same length so from the
root down to here
we have three nodes from the root down
to here we have three nodes as well so
those are the two leaf nodes we have
here
we also have a leaf node on the left
side but clearly we see
that there's only two nodes in this path
so out of all those paths what's the max
length of course it's three so you can
see that that's what our output is going
to be in this problem
so the simplest way to solve this
problem is recursive depth first search
now
what's the base case we're using
recursion so first let's think of the
base case obviously if we had just an
empty tree right like what's what if
this was our tree what are we gonna
return of course
zero right the max depth of an empty
tree is just zero
what about if we just had one node and
no
children right okay we'd do this
recursively so we'd get to the first
node right we'd say okay we at least
have
one node then we'd say okay let's just
find the max of the left subtree and the
max of the
the right subtree both of those are
gonna return zero right so
once we get back to the root what are we
gonna say we're gonna say okay the left
and right subtree were zero
so the maximum of the left and right
subtree is also zero so what we're going
to return from the perspective of this
root node is just going to be 1
plus the max 1 plus the max
of the left and right results basically
the max of
the left and right subtrees in which
case it was both
zero so of course in this problem we're
going to return one as the max step now
let's look at this more general example
that they gave us so obviously we're
going to do the same thing we're going
to get to the root say okay we found
at least one node
so the depth is at least one and then
we're going to return the max
of we're going to return the max of
the left and right subtrees plus one and
why are we doing it this way well you
can
see that we found this node but now we
have sub problems right we need to know
what's the max path what's the max
depth and we'll have to search the left
subtree and we'll have to search the
right subtree so we're not even
considering this node anymore we're
doing recursion we're looking at the sub
problem what's the max depth of this
left subtree well of course it's just a
node a single node with no children so
of course the max depth is going to be
1.
similarly let's do the right subtree and
so again this is going to be our
recursive case right we have one node
and from then this node's perspective
we're going to run recursion again we're
going to look at the left subtree and
the right subtree both of which are
going to return one
so then of course from this node's
perspective we're going to return to
the max depth of this subtree is 2 the
max depth of the left sub tree
is 1. so now when we get back up here
we're saying okay from the perspective
of this node we're going to return 1
plus the max of left and right the max
is clearly 2.
so from this node's perspective we're
going to return 3 the max depth is 3. so
let's code this up recursively
it's literally just going to be this
line that i just wrote and the base case
and since we are traversing the entire
tree the time complexity is going to be
big o
of n the memory complexity is just going
to be the height of the tree which also
could be worst case big of n if it's a
not
if it's not a balanced binary tree so
with recursion we always want to take
care of the base case first so if the
root
is null then of course we're just going
to return 0 that's the max depth
otherwise we're going to return 1
plus the max of what our dfs of left
returns or in this case it's not dfs
it's actually called max
depth and since we're inside of the
function in python you have to
you know say self.max depth and then run
that
on the left subtree and also run it on
the
right subtree now to make this line
shorter i could actually store the
result of both of these function calls
in variables but i think this one liner
is pretty much good enough so we're just
taking
the result of both of these function
calls figuring out what's the max of it
so what's the max subtree's depth
of both of the sub trees and then just
adding one to it because we know that
the current node the current root node
that we're traversing
is definitely not null so this
calculation will work out let's submit
it
and of course i'm showing that i can't
even solve easy problems so it's not
called
node it's actually called root hopefully
you were able to catch that
but yeah so this is the entire problem
but what if your
interviewer or what if you just want to
do this for learning purposes
you want to solve this problem without
recursion well there's two ways to do it
iterative depth first search or
iterative breadth first search and i'm
going to show you both of those right
now
now there's not a lot of benefits to
using breadth first search on this
problem
compared to just doing dfs recursively
mainly that you just don't have to do
recursion at all
the time complexity is still going to be
the same the memory complexity is still
going to be the same
but let's still do this for learning
purposes so breadth first search on a
tree is basically
level order traversal we're traversing
each level
by level until we get to the end or the
last
level and then we can't continue anymore
so you can kind of see how breath for
search is a pretty intuitive way to find
the max
depth right we're basically counting the
number of levels we have
so here we see okay we have one level
next we see
we have two levels oh this is the third
level and we can't go any lower so
what's the number of levels that we had
we had three
that's the number of levels is basically
going to be the same as the max
depth so now the only problem is how are
we actually going to code this
up now typically bfs involves a queue or
a
deck a dq or however you call it and so
the way it's going to work is the queue
is initially just going to have the root
value
so i'm going to kind of represent this
array as the queue so initially we're
just going to put the root
in the queue right so now we're going to
say okay what's the length of our queue
this is these are the elements currently
in our queue and this these are all at
level one
so now we're going to go through every
node in our queue we only have one and
we're going to take three
now we're going to remove it from our
queue and we're going to replace it with
its children
9 and 20. so let's add 9 and
20 to the queue so now
this is our second level right these
elements that we have here are our
second
level of the queue the second level of
the tree so we're going to do the exact
same thing
with these two nodes we're going to take
the first one 9
get rid of it we see 9 is here now we're
going to replace it with its children it
doesn't have any children so we don't
have to replace it with anything right
but we're going to keep going
now we're going to go to the second one
20 remove that from
our q and replace it with its children
what are its children we have 15
and 17 so let's add 15 i ran out of
space but that's okay
and 17 to our q now this
portion is the next level it's level
three
so let's continue to go so 15 is the
first one let's pop it let's get rid of
it replace it with its children it
doesn't have any children
so it's a base case next one seven okay
i wrote 17 but it's actually seven sorry
about that i'm not paying attention
but okay we're gonna get rid of this
seven and we're gonna see okay seven did
not have any children either
so now when we when we continue to go
we're gonna see okay there's nothing
left in our queue so we have to stop
right
that's how we know we're done traversing
the entire tree when we went through
every single node
what's the max level that we actually
got to of course it was three so that's
what we're going to end up returning the
max
depth of this this tree was three okay
so now let's get rid of this and
actually do
that solution so another base case or
the same basis i'm just going to say
if not root we can still return zero so
if there's no root then we're gonna
return zero
and we're also going to maintain the
current level that we're at and we're
gonna have a queue which in this case
is going to be a deck and initially
we're going to initialize this queue
with just a single value the
root i think most libraries do have a
queue structure so
we're going to initialize our queue like
that we're going to have our level
initially at one we're gonna keep going
until the queue is empty right now so
now we want to go through the queue and
remove
every element that's currently in it
right so however many are in it so we're
gonna say for i
in range length of the queue at this
current time right so we're going to
take a snapshot of the length of the
queue maybe it has one element maybe it
has two
we're going to take a snapshot remove
all of those and then add the children
so basically traverse the entire level
and then add the next level
and then once we're done with that
entire loop we're going to increase the
number of levels
so for every node in the queue we're
going to go ahead and pop from the left
just like we did in the picture we're
always going to be popping from the left
of the queue and we're always going to
be adding to the right of the queue so
we're going to pop a node
and then we're going to go ahead and add
its children to
the queue only if the children are not
null so if node.left is non-null
then we're going to go ahead and say q
dot append node
dot left if node.right is non-null then
we're going to append that one
as well so q dot append no dot
right and actually if we're going to be
doing it this way we should probably
initialize our level to
zero so you can see that we're never
going to be adding
null nodes to our our queue so every
time
our queue is non-empty we can be sure
that there's at least
a non-empty node in the queue right so
we're basically counting the number of
times our q is not
is going to be non-empty so each time it
is we can basically increment the number
of levels
and then at the end once our q is
finally empty we know that we have
totaled up the number of levels and we
can go ahead and return that
so you can see this solution also works
and it's also pretty efficient so this
is the breadth first search solution
but there's one more solution i want to
show you the iterative
depth first search solution basically
depth first search without using
recursion
so now we're going to do iterative depth
first search and we're going to be
needing a stack data structure because
we're basically going to be
emulating the call stack the recursive
call stack right so
you know in a recursive dfs we go to
this node right and then we go to the
left sub tree right and when we're done
with the left sub tree
then we pop back up to the three
and then we go down to you know the
right subtree etc
right that's like in in order dfs but
we're going to be implementing
pre-order dfs with a stack because
pre-order is actually by far the
easiest one to do iteratively so what
we're going to do is we're going to say
okay
come to this node process this node
right then
add the children to the stack the left
and right children right
now in now our normal pre-order
traversal we'll do the left subtree
first so what we're going to do is now
say okay
let's do the left subtree well well
we're going to go to the left subtree
it's pre-order so we're going to process
this then we're going to do its children
well it doesn't have any children right
so now what are we going to do well this
one was added to the stack
so then we can go ahead and process this
one and add its children to the stack
and then we're going to process this one
it doesn't have any children and then
this one's going to be at the top of the
stack because we just popped this one
and then we can process this one and
then we're done right so we're going to
do that
and as we do it iteratively we're not
just going to be adding the nodes
themselves to the stack but we're also
for each node going to be adding to
the depth of each node because we can
easily do that right we know this is
going to be depth one
when we add the left and right children
we're gonna say okay these are at depth
two
when we add these two we're gonna say
these are at depth three
so we're just gonna try to visit every
single node find the node that had the
greatest depth and then we can return
that
so initially we're gonna start with node
three at depth
1 in our stack so now we're going to pop
from our stack so let's
pop this node and we process it so so
far the max depth we found was
1 and let's add its children to the
stack so let's add 20 to the stack
and let's add 9 to the stack and each of
these are going to have a depth of
2. so now this is technically the top of
the stack even though it's the bottom so
let's pop from the top of the stack
pop this one that's node 9 so now we've
found a max depth of two that's better
than one
and now let's also add the children of
this of course it doesn't have any
children so we're done with
these so now what's at the top of our
stack that's
that's well we popped this one we popped
this this is at the top of the stack now
so let's pop this one
we pop 20. it also has a max depth of
two so we don't update the result but
now we can add its children
to the stack and the depth of course is
going to be plus one so both of these
are gonna have a depth of 20
of three we're going to add 7 and 15 to
the stack so now let's pop the top of
the stack 15
pop this it has a max depth of 3 so
we've updated the result pop one more
time this
also had a max depth of three so we're
done with that we process this node
and neither of these had any children so
now we're done with the dfs
so that's basically how it's going to
work it's pretty straightforward at
least if you're doing it with pre-order
dfs
with a stack okay so finally for the
last solution so this was bfs but now
we're going to be doing iterative dfs
we're going to leave this
initial case if the root is null we're
going to return 0
and our stack otherwise is just going to
have one single
value on it the root but remember we're
also maintaining the depth so we're
gonna add a pair of values we're gonna
add the root which is the node
and we're gonna add it has a depth of
one and now we're gonna continue to go
while our stack is non-empty so this is
pretty similar to bfs
but we don't actually need nested loops
so
now we're going to pop from the stack
stack dot pop we're popping two values
remember we're getting the node and
we're getting its
depth and so what we're going to say now
is we're going to say if the node is
non-null
you'll see why i'm going to do this in a
moment because it's possible the node
could be null so if it's non-null
what we're going to do is we want to
update our result now initially we're
going to set our result
equal to 1 because we know we do have at
least
a 1. and so if we pop this node and it's
non-null then we can potentially update
our result so we'll set the result equal
to the max of itself
and the depth of the node that we just
popped
and then what we're going to do is to
our stack we're going to add the
children
of of this node and we're gonna add both
of them together so node.left
node.right but we're not even checking
it could be possible that these children
are null so we technically might add
null nodes to our stack which is
different than the drawing i showed but
we're showing that if we do add a null
node we're going to pop from we're going
to pop it from the stack but we're not
actually going to do anything with it
right this
if statement will prevent us from
actually using that
null node so we're just going to ignore
the null nodes
and actually we're we're adding both of
these nodes but we also want to add the
depth of each of them so that's what i'm
going to
modify right now so we're going to
append the left node
and we're going to append it with its
depth which is just going to be the
depth of the node that we just popped
plus one and we're going to do the exact
same thing for node
dot write so
copy paste and update this so we're
adding both of the nodes even if they're
null we're adding them
and then we're just going to continue
through the stack until the stack
becomes
empty and then once that is done we can
go ahead and return
the result and this is the entire code
and i actually just realized
that we can actually simplify the code a
little bit we can actually get rid of
these two first lines
and set the result initially equal to
zero
so then if we do have a null root node
the loop will execute we'll pop this
but then the if statement won't execute
so then the result will stay zero and
then we'll end up returning zero but of
course if the root is non-null
we will end up updating the result so
this is the third and final solution
that i wanted to show you they all have
basically the same time and space
complexity
but there's definitely variations with
each of these solutions so i hope that
this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching